today actually is a very special day for
me because it is my birthday and so
thanks for all of you for joining the
party but every time you throw a party
there's someone there to spoil it all
right and I'm a physicist
and this time is not I brought another
physicist along to do so his name is
Albert Einstein also Albert and he's the
one who said that a person who has not
made his great contribution to sighs to
science by the age of 30 will never do
so now you don't need to check Wikipedia
that I'm beyond 30 so so effectively
what he is telling me and us that when
it comes to my science I'm a dad vote
well luckily I had my share of luck
within my career around age 28 I became
very interested in networks and a few
years later we managed to kind of
publish a few key papers that reported
the discovery of scale-free networks and
really gave birth to a new disciplines
that we call network science today and
if you really care about it you can get
a PhD now in network science in Budapest
in Boston and you can study it all over
the world a few years later when I moved
to Harvard first as a sabbatical I
became interested in another type of
networks and that was that time the
networks between ourselves how the genes
are the proteins and the metabolites
linked to each other and how they
connect to disease and that also that
interest led to a major explosion
between medicine including the networked
medicine division at Harvard that has
more than 300 researchers who are using
this perspective to treat patients and
develop new cures and a few years ago I
thought that I would take this idea of
networks and expertise we had in
networks in a different area that is to
understand success
and why did we do that well we told that
you know to some degree our success is
determined by the networks were a part
of the our networks can pull us forward
push us forward they can pull us back
and I was curious if we could use the
knowledge in Big Data and expertise so
we developed an networks to really
quantify how these things happened this
is a result from that what you see here
is a network of galleries and museums
that connect to each other and through
this map that we mapped out of you last
year we are able to predict very
accurately the success of an artist if
you give me the first five exhibits that
he or she had in her career well as we
thought about success we realized that
success is not only about networks
there's so many other dimensions to that
and you know one of the things we need
for a success obviously is performance
so let's define what's the difference
between performance and success well
performance system is what you do how
fast you run what kind of paintings you
paint what kind of papers you published
however in our working definition
success is about what does the community
notices from what you did from your
performance
how does it acknowledge it and how does
it rewards you for it in other terms
your performance is about you but your
success is about all of us and this was
a very important shift for us because in
the moment we defined success as being a
collective measure that the community
provides to us it became measurable
because if it's in the community there
are multiple data points talk about that
so now we believe and we go to school we
exercise we practice because we believe
that performance leads to success but
the way we actually started to explore
we realize that performance and success
are very very different animals when it
comes to the mathematics of the problem
and let me illustrate that so what you
see here is the fastest man on earth
Usain Bolt
and of course he wins most of the
competitions that he enters
and we know he's the fastest surf
because we have a chronometer to measure
his speed but what is interesting about
him is that when he wins he doesn't do
so by really significantly outlining his
competition he's running at most a
percent faster than the one who loses
the race and not only that he runs only
1% faster than the second one but he
doesn't run ten times faster than I do
and I'm not a good runner trust me on
that
so and every time we are able to measure
performance we notice something very
interesting that his performance is
bounded what it means is that there are
no huge variation see human performance
it worries it varies only in a narrow
range and we do need a chronometer to
measure the differences this is not to
say that we cannot see the good from the
best one but the best ones are very hard
to distinguish and the problem with that
is that most of us work in areas where
we do not have a chronometer to gauge
our performance all right performance is
bounded there are no huge differences
between us when we come short
performance how about success well let's
switch to a different topic like books
right one measure of success for writers
is how many people read your work and so
when my previous book came out in 2009 I
was in York talking with my editor and I
was interested who is the competition
and I had some fabulous won you know
that week Ben brow came out I stood up
with the last symbol and the last song
also came out right it's in across parks
and when you just look at the list you
realize you know performance wise
there's hardly any difference between
these books or mine
right and and you know so maybe if
Nicholas Sparks team works a little
harder he could easily be number one
right because it's almost by accident
who ended up on the top so it said let's
look at the numbers I'm a data person
right so let's see what was this lower
the sales for Nicholas Sparks and turns
out that that opening weekend Nicholas
Sparks sold more than a hundred thousand
copies which is amazing number you need
you can actually get the
top of the New York Times bestseller
list by Twitter selling 10,000 copies a
week so he tenfold over came came what
it needed to be number one yet he wasn't
number one why because there was Dan
Brown who sold 1.2 million copies that
weekend and the reason I like these
numbers because it shows that really
when it comes to success its unbounded
that the best is not just slightly gets
not the best doesn't only get slightly
more than the second-best but gets
orders of magnitude more because success
is a collective measure we give it to
them rather than we earn it through our
performance so so really this is kind of
one of the things we realize is that
performance what we do is bummed it but
success which is collective is unbounded
which makes you wonder how do you get
these huge differences in success when
you have so tiny differences in
performance and recently I published a
book that I devoted to that very
question and they didn't give me enough
time to go over all of that so I'm gonna
go back to the question of alright you
have success when should that appear so
let's go back to the party spoiler and
ask ourselves why did Einstein make this
ridiculous statement that only before it
heard it you could actually be creative
well because he looked around himself
and he saw all these fabulous physicists
that created quantum mechanics and
modern physics and they were all in
their 20s and early thirties when they
did so and it's not only him it's not
only observational bias because there's
actually a war field of genius research
that has documented the fact that if you
look at the people we admire from the
past and they look at what age did they
make their biggest contribution whether
that's music whether that's science
whether that's engineering most of them
tend to do so in their twenties thirties
late early forties it most but there's a
problem with this a genius research well
first of all it created the impression
to us that creativity equus youth which
is painful right
and and it also has an observational
bias because it only looks at geniuses
and doesn't look at ordinary scientists
right and doesn't look at all of us and
asking is it really true that creativity
vanishes as we age so that's exactly
what we try to do and this is important
for that to actually have references so
let's look at lore dairy scientists like
myself and like it let's look at my
career so what you see here is all the
papers that I published from my very
first paper in 1989 that I was still in
Romania when I did so tale kind of this
year and vertically you see the impact
of the paper that is how many citations
how many other papers have been written
kind of that cited that work and when
you look at that you see that my career
has three roughly different stages I had
the first tenure I could work a lot and
I don't achieve much no one seems to
care about what I do right there's
hardly an impact that time I was doing
material science and then I kind of
discovered for myself networks and then
started publishing in networks and that
led one high-impact paper to the other
one and it really felt good that was
that stage of my career
so the question is what happens right
now and we don't know because there
hasn't been enough time passed yet to
actually figure out how much impact
those papers will get it takes time to
require well when you look at the data
it seems to be that Einstein the genius
research is right and on that stage of
my career so we said okay let's figure
out how does this really happen first in
science right and in order to not to
have the kind of selection bias to look
only a geniuses we ended up
reconstructing the career of every
single scientist still 1900 till today
and finding for all scientists what was
their personal best whether they got the
Nobel Prize or they never did so or no
one knows what they did even their
personal best and that's what you see
actually in this slide each line is a
career and when you have a light blue
dot on the top of the career says that
was their personal best and the question
is when did they actually made their
biggest discovery and to quantify that
we look at what's the probability that
you make your business discovery let's
say one two three or ten years into your
career we're not looking at village
we're looking what we call academic is
your academic age starts when you
publish your first papers I know some of
you are still babies and so so let's
look at the probability that you publish
your highest impact paper and what you
see is indeed the genius research is
right
most scientists tend to publish their
highest impact paper in the first 10-15
years in their career and and it tanks
after that so it tanks so fast that I'm
about I'm exactly thirty years into my
career and the chance that I will
publish a paper that would have higher
impact that anything that I did before
is less than 1% I am in that stage of my
career according to this data but
there's a problem with that it's it's
we're not looking at we're not doing
controls properly so the control would
be how would scientists look like who
help makes random contribution to
science so or what is the productivity
of the scientists when do they write
papers so we measure the productivity
and
amazingly the productivity your
likelihood of writing a paper in your
110 or 20 in your career is
indistinguishable from the likelihood of
having the impact in that part of your
career and to make a long story short
after lots of statistical tests there's
only one explanation for that that
really the way we scientists work is
that every single paper we write every
project we do has exactly the same
chance of varying our personal best that
is discovery is like a lottery right and
like a lottery ticket and then the more
lottery tickets we buy the higher is the
chance and it happens to be so that most
scientists buy most of their lottery
tickets in the first 10-15 years of
their career and after that their
productivity decreases they're not
buying any more lottery tickets so it
looks like as if they would not be
creative in the reality they stopped
trying so when we actually put the data
together the conclusion is very simple
success can come at any time it could be
your very first or very last paper of
your career it's totally random in the
player in the space of the projects it
is the productivity that changes let me
illustrate that here is Frank Vilsack
who got the Nobel Prize in Physics for
the very first paper he ever wrote in
his career as a graduate student more
interesting is john flan who at age 70
was forcefully retired by a university
they shot his lap down and at that
moment he moved to Virginia Commonwealth
University opened another lab and it is
there at age 72 that he published a
paper for which 15 years later he got
the Nobel Prize for chemistry and and
you think ok what science is special
right but what about other areas where
we need to be creative so let me take
another typical example right
entrepreneurship Silicon Valley the land
of the youth right and indeed when you
look at it you realize that the the
biggest awards the TechCrunch awards and
other awards are all going to people
aged kind of on average age for them is
kind of late her late twenties very
returnees you look at who do the visas
give the money to some of the biggest
waves VC firms all people in their early
thirties which of course we know there
is this Atos in Silicon Valley that huge
echo success not when you look at the
data because it's not only about forming
a company forming a company's like
productivity trying trying trying when
you look at how each of these
individuals actually put out a
successful company a successful exit and
recently some of our colleagues look at
exactly that question and it turns out
that yes those in the 20s and 30s put
out a huge number of companies forum
lots of companies but most of them go
bust and when you look at the successful
exits what you see in this particular
plot the older you are the more likely
that you will actually hit the stock
market or sold a car or sell their
company successfully this is so strong
actually that if you are in the 50s
you're twice as likely to actually have
a successful exit then if you are in
your thirties so
so at the end what is that we see
actually what we see is that creativity
has no age productivity does right and
which is telling me you know that at the
end of the day you know if you keep
trying you know you could still succeed
and succeed over and over so my
conclusion is very simple
I'm off the stage back in my lab thank
you
[Applause]